we will put him on a bus that we want to
put on it
put that [ __ ] down jackass the Robin
challenge is where you get as many
stupid people as possible to eat some of
the most spiciest food on earth what you
don't have water or water thing broke on
our fridge so when do you guys have like
orange juice anything like I'm not
drinking guys that's gonna kill you
hey hey David you trying to die on a
pyro Ranger all right
there's nothing there's kids that look
up to you right now and they're gonna
look up to me is it not eat is the blue
hard red you can't do it don't feel so
sad
no I don't make them feel stronger that
they can do it no blue card you can't do
it I guess I can't go to college if
you've never had this from an I think
it's like their food ramen is what is
called it's [ __ ] it tastes great but
I'm not going to like it tastes
fantastic it's just that there's like a
border of spiciness where it just goes a
little too far there's regular spicy if
it makes you know sweat and they're
spicy above that that makes your chest
sweat and the spicy above that is where
your [ __ ] bleeds you should be
getting bunch of leather jacket okay
buddy looks like it's yours now as spicy
as the spicy Robin challenge is we of
course had to up the quotient and we got
these three spicy ass bottles of hot
sauce I don't remember what the names
you are exactly I think I think one was
like death Inferno and then [ __ ] your
mom but we decided to roll up die to see
who gets to choose what hasa hot sauce
they're going to eat yeah
aha Oh God got a six done it's a
20-sided die nothing so who's next
you saw it witness you have a - how do
you done do you shake it yeah one this
one is called sudden death this one's
called after death this was called
original death I was just all opinion
now he'll pinion I had to figure out
which one's hotter this or this one I
mean essentially when it comes to the
thought process of of choosing who gets
what hot sauce I just based it on who I
hated more and it was Yoshi just because
you know he's fit for no [ __ ] reason
oh this is hottest hey you should try it
a shooter that's crazy you're gonna take
this one you're getting second hottest
you know right now roll the dice for how
many wrong oh you're joking - haha I'm
good at this one haha we have to finish
holding yes what you could join 1 1 1 1
1
oh man the shame is like 100 huge
alright yeah 3 2 1
bottom huh [ __ ] it's like I fail to
understand why people would eat this
[ __ ] like with the moment I took the
first bite from the food my full face
just lit on fire
oh it's hot oh my god I'm sweating Paul
I was like honestly actually I read the
reason why people like spicy food is
because they like the pain which means
that [ __ ] masochist you sick [ __ ]
freaks [ __ ] yourself why did you make
such big quantity who cooked this I did
why have you made a small investment
would have to eat less you don't even
make sense you're doing this to yourself
you look hot you're right we'll get it
out he hasn't finished his dinner I was
just [ __ ] happen this that's yours
I'm back in my flat that's way more than
what did you know exactly what you gave
me yo she's [ __ ] blind this [ __ ] by
the way I gave him as a joke like a part
of my noodles and then when he returned
to back he returned my noodles and then
some back on my plane Eagles were even
nevermind this gets worse dude I'm
slowly a mofo I'm lactose I can't have
that kill this you'll miss your mom you
know I've liked of this Iko yeah bread I
also hear is a great absorbing for spicy
food
decided to absorb the spice with the
bread oh my comfort yeah we're still lap
you know failed all those kids I just
realized I ate the bread that this way
yeah alright affair did no that [ __ ]
don't put too much it's gonna feel weird
like that [ __ ] gays gonna me finish
okay is your brother
he's the one that bugged out and you
know what you knew it
yeah all over yesterday yeah it's got
more like I did no such thing
do you do you have video proof are you
so with the purpose of that what doesn't
like have anything to do with what we're
doing today
just eat spicy food for no [ __ ]
reason what happens when you have a
useless [ __ ] show such as that one in
there
leave that [ __ ] in the edit Danielle the
dumbest hashtag Danielle's a dumbass in
all this is a prize that they want or
Peter won because he's the only one who
really finished my first why would he
didn't finish it he did you give some do
you know I gave him the stuff he gave me
mommy
nothing you gave me you should give me
the stuff that you gave me and stuff
that I gave you
has become fully alive Indonesian people
are known to be great liars he's not
even in these Chinese someone's lighter
you have your Chinese yeah it was good
in yell with the cigar Sabrosa of course
you guys can go ahead and check them out
on their channel on youtube i think
that's called
youtube.com slash apartment 210 but go
support their [ __ ] they are aspiring
actors and you can see them on their
journey and see what they're doing we
obviously don't get to see a lot of each
other because we are busy doing our own
things but every now and then when you
do get to see friends and you haven't
seen it in a while
great things happen because my ballsack
and Hispanics Power Rangers blue suit
you